service lima die duw ist heute
wissenschaftlich geprüft freunde der
sonne ich bin es wieder mal eure
chemikerin des vertrauens ich bin über
dieses video von zehn muslime gestolpert
fünf die talks drink rezepte zum
abnehmen sache aber auch und schöne haut
er hat eine schöne haut das muss man
sagen ich werde jede zutat in zehn video
durchgehen und schauen warum ist diese
zutat angeblich gesund gibt es dafür
wissenschaftliche belege und ich werde
zeit tiefe gepresst verteilen und am
ende werde ich eine art
wissenschaftliche gesamtnote für das
video geben letzten ersten die zu
extreme braucht ihr orangen zitronen
apfelessig und wasser und kurkuma und
keller von orangen zitronen halten
jeweils 50 milligramm vitamin c pro 100
gramm vitamin c ist ein sogenanntes
antioxidans und was viele vielleicht
nicht wissen vitamin c wird auch
gebraucht um kollagen herzustellen
kollagen ist eine struktur protein das
zur ausbildung von haut und anderen
gewebe benötigt orange und zitrone
abruft apfelessig da plötzlich wirkt
dabei so antibakteriell für den körper
führerhaus ist sehr gut für ihre
verdauung und ideal für nicht sachen
braucht es geht hier nicht zwingend es
sich vom apfel es geht hier um das
molekül der essigsäure dass in jedem
essig drin ist aber kann dieses molekül
irgendwas claim nummer eins es soll eine
antibakterielle wirkung haben dazu gibt
es leider nicht viele forscher unfall
nicht bei mensch bei garnelen hat man
beobachtet dass essigsäure deren
immunsystem stärken könnte aber davon
abgesehen gibt es tatsächlich nicht so
viele wissenschaftliche hinweise claim
nummer zwei es ich es gut für die haut
auch hier gibt es keine
wissenschaftlichen belege
stattdessen gibt es nur ein paar studien
zur äußeren anwendung von essig auf der
haut und davon ist abzuraten
clay nummer vier essigsäure kurbelt die
fettverbrennung
es gibt eine einzige japanische studie
die gezeigt hat dass menschen mithilfe
von essigsäure abnehmen können doch
diese ergebnisse konnten bisher nicht
noch einmal reproduziert werden es soll
außerdem angeblich schneller länger satt
machen auch das könnte der grund dafür
sein dass man potenziell abnehmen könnte
doch die wissenschaft hinterfragt auch
dass man geht er davon aus dass es halt
einfach nicht so geil ist es sich zu
treten so dass man danach schlicht und
einfach kein bock mehr hat irgendwas zu
sich zu nehmen weil einem auch ein
bisschen schlecht wie es zum beispiel
unterstrich es soll reiseempfehlung
wissenschaftlich nicht haltbar
vor allem wenn man auch bedenkt dass
essigsäure zu reizungen oder
verletzungen der speiseröhre führen kann
essigsäure not ruft und cayennepfeffer
das magische moleküle im cayenne pfeffer
ist das capsaicin das schärfe molekül
das zum beispiel auch in chilis inhalten
ist es gibt wissenschaftliche hinweise
dass capsaicin die energie und
fettverbrennung leicht erhöhen und den
appetit leicht verringern könnte im
anbetracht der aktuellen datenlage und
im zweifel für den angeklagten sage ich
cayennepfeffer überprüft aber melanie
machst mir bitte noch ein abruf debatten
danke das gefährlich über solchen sachen
ist das eine riesige diät industrie gibt
die dann sofort cups ice linien fielen
auf den markt bringt sobald es erste
wissenschaftliche hinweise gibt oder
meinetwegen auch keine
wissenschaftlichen hinweise gerade bei
capsaicin ist besonders gefährlich denn
hier gab es einzelne fälle wo gesunde
menschen mit capsaicin kellen abnehmen
wollten und einen herzinfarkt erlitten
haben also bitte übertreibt es nicht
dasselbe ist kummer typisch indisches
oder asiatisches gewürze wird gewonnen
aus der cocoon pflanze oder auch geld
wurzel genannt wichtige moleküle in kuba
ist curcumin und kurkuma soll angeblich
entzündungshemmend sein schmerzlindernd
und sogar gegen depression und alzheimer
helfen
curcumin wurde tatsächlich auch schon
viel untersuchte es gibt über 120
klinische studien allerdings ohne erfolg
das mag vielleicht
einfach daran liegen dass q q mit einer
unglaublich schlechte bioverfügbarkeit
hat schlechte bioverfügbarkeit heißt wir
können zwar jetzt macht sich von dem
zeug essen aber unser körper kann das
gar nicht aufnehmen das heißt das meiste
wird einfach ausgeschieden oder zersetzt
kurkuma nagelprobe kommt zum nächsten
drink trinkt nummer zeit dazu braucht ja
einmal limetten für die limetten gilt
ähnliches viel p die zitrone und orange
abruft kurs wasser reich an elektrolyten
ist also ist ein direktes sportgetränk
es nicht nach reich an elektrolyten das
stimmt und sich hier steht jetzt was zu
kokoswasser und zwar kokoswasser
neutralisiert den ph-wert des körpers
es ist ein allgemeiner und erstaunlich
weit verbreiteter irrtum nämlich dass
unser essen der ph wert unseres körpers
beeinflussen kann und dass bestimmte
lebensmittel uns über st der ph wert
sagt aus wie sauer oder basisch ein
stoff ist die skala geht von null sehr
sauer bis 14 sehr basisch und in der
mitte liegt der ph-wert 7 der ist
neutral dann kann ich auch nur davon
ausgehen dass mit ph wert des körpers
der ph wert unseres blutes gemeint ist
der neutral bleiben soll
denn in unserem körper gibt es durchaus
auch sauren ph werte wie zb unserem
magen oder unserem da der ph wert im
blut soll tatsächlich bei ziemlich genau
7,4 liegen und es gibt ein hochkomplexes
puffer system das dafür sorgt dass der
ph-wert auch genau da bleibt über den
kleinsten abweichungen von 7,4 wird es
bereits gefährlich ab 7,37 spricht man
schon von einer sogenannten ab sie dose
bei 7,43 von einer alka lose das ist zu
vermeiden
diesen sehr gefährlichen kleinen
abweichungen vom ph-wert kommen akku
zustande zum beispiel durch atemnot oder
durch hyperventilieren oder auch
chronisch durch nierenversagen durch
pollini oder durch starken durchfall
nicht durch essen geprüft
kommen wir zu den kia sein der grund
warum chrisam sehr gehypt werden ist
wegen der omega 3 fettsäuren welche habt
ihr schon mal gehört dass fisch gut ist
weil das fett im fisch omega 3
fettsäuren sind omega 3 fettsäuren sind
gute fette denn es sind lebenswichtige
fette die der körper außerdem nicht
selbst herstellen kann ist also wichtig
dass wir auch mega 3 fettsäuren zu uns
nehmen über die nahrung in fischers wie
gesagt drin in müssen ist es drin und zb
auch in kasan
generell ist es wissenschaftliche
absolut empfehlenswert volle curler zu
essen hier samen blazer oder generell
freundes cortázar
trinkt nummer drei wir haben kurkuma das
hatten wir schon break führt wieder
einen fußbruch aber im gegensatz zu
anderen zitrusfrüchten wie die great
wird hier zur queen der fettverbrennung
gekürt und es wird mehr zahlt sich das
wissenschaftlich genau anzuschauen viel
forschung gibt es dazu nicht in einer
studie gab es für eine testgruppe sechs
wochen lang anderthalb grey goose pro
tag die ergebnisse beim abnehmen schien
die briten nichts zu essen
aber das ist eigentlich viel wichtiger
einige risikofaktoren für
herz-kreislauferkrankungen wurde niedrig
also great als verbrenner norden
grapefruit als gesundes lebensmittel
bringt immer wieder ganz kurz können wir
haben mich und bananen abhandeln für
mich ist ein guter milchersatz wenn man
vegan oder natur sie intolerant
unterwegs ist ist eine gesunde sache ist
sei denn das setzt auch extra zucker
hinzu gesetzt da kann man mal ein
bisschen darauf achten bei den ganzen
milch ersatzprodukten bei den ganzen
pflanzen milchprodukten ist oft zucker
für den geschmack hinzugesetzt das
natürlich nie so geil banane gibt es
nicht viel zu sagen so wie das meiste
obst absolut empfehlenswert vitamine
ballaststoffe kalium und auch andere
mineralien abruf der spinat isst solchen
reisen spinat enthält eisen 100 gramm
spinat enthalten 2,6 milligramm eisen
das ist nicht wenig aber es ist auch
nicht so überwältigend viel wie man so
oft hört es gibt lebensmittel die
durchaus mehr eisen enthalten zum
beispiel pistazien und hinzu kommt noch
dass spinat oxalsäure internet oxalsäure
bindet an das eisen und macht es dadurch
weniger bio verfügbar
trotz allem ist platt finale gesunde
sache enthält auch vitamin a und c sogar
und natürlich viele ballaststoffe
insofern
er prüft den sellerie der entschlackend
und blut hoch senkt zu sellerie gibt es
auch nicht besonders viel forschung vor
allem besteht sellerie fast nur aus
wasser und ist daher nicht besonders
nährstoffreich und sellerie ist aber
trotz allem ein gesundes lebensmittel
enthält zum beispiel auch vitamin k
prinzipiell prüft entschlackend
bluthochdruck senken dazu habe ich
keinerlei wissenschaftliche budget
gefunden insofern das richtige tode
hatten wir schon leinsamen das meiste
was auch wird ihr sagen gilt insofern
auch ruft freie meinung dazu sagen muss
wenn man langsam hier sagen einfach so
trinkt ist die bioverfügbarkeit auch
nicht optimal also besser ist immer noch
möglich darauf rum card oder die vorher
zahlt damit die nährstoffe auch wirklich
zugänglich aber irgendwie enthält ein
molekül namens ging gar all jene zeit
schmerzlindernde und entzündungshemmende
effekte auch bei anderen inhaltsstoffen
von ihnen hat man den zyklus hemmende
effekte tessin war
aber vorsicht bei überdosierung wie bei
allen sachen in diesem fall kann es zu
sodbrennen und durchfall führen das
waren die fünf drinks ich wollte noch
was zur die talks allgemein sagen die
talks heißt der sophie wir entgiften die
idee ist dass man zum beispiel mit hilfe
bestimmter lebensmittel toxine
giftstoffe aus dem körper befreit welche
toxine das genau sind und auf welchen
mechanismus sie den körper verlassen das
wird in der regel sehr vage nur
beschrieben das liegt daran dass es für
dieses ganze die talks ding überhaupt
keine wissenschaftliche basis gibt
problem ist natürlich dass diese die
talks ideen schweinegeld gemacht wird es
gibt einen ganzen markt diät ratgeber
diätpillen irgendwelche custom made saft
kuren die für ein mit für viel geld
zusammen gestellt werden pflaster die
man sich auf dem fuß klebt und wo die
toxine durch die fußsohle den körper
verlassen sollen im besten fall verliert
man einfach nur ein haufen geld für
nichts im schlimmsten fall kann es sogar
gefährlich werden wie bei unserem
beispiel mit dem kz in wer seinen körper
aber wirklich entgiften möchte dem
empfehle ich zwei sachen nämlich erstens
leber und zwar inszenieren
diese organe sind genau dafür gemacht
nämlich stoffe die der körper nicht
braucht herauszufiltern und
die talks als gesamte idee bekommt von
mir ein ganz klares nord abruft was ich
jetzt das wissenschaftliche gesamturteil
für dieses video abgesehen davon dass
diese drinks nicht wirklich entgiften
ist viel gesundes tier dabei und ich bin
es wirklich gut dass harry mit diesem
ästhetisch höchst ansprechenden video
lust auf gesunde ernährung macht nicht
alles was ihr behauptet wird es
wissenschaftlich belegt aber hier werden
noch keine gefährlichen infos verbreitet
es ich würde ich jetzt selbst nicht
trinken das auch nicht empfehlen aber
abgesehen davon kann man mit diesen
drinks nicht viel falsch machen
insofern gebe ich diesem video ein
gesamturteil von schadet nicht so
welchen youtuber oder welches youtube
video soll ich als nächstes
wissenschaftlich prüfen schreibt es in
die kommentare
freunde der sonne etwas berichtet
passiert
meine tore für den grimme online award
nominiert
und ihr könnt abstimmen dallas führte
gruppenpreis dass die pflege der mission